Now, we're gonna talk a little bit about vowel sounds...
...and this information is applicable to every vowel sound you'll work with.
A vowel sound is an uninterrupted stream of air or breath, in which the articulators do not move.
That means there's no movement once you start the sound.
And here's an example.
/i/, /ɛ/, /ɒ/.
Notice in each of those three voicings of /i/, /ɛ/, and /ɒ/,...
...there was no movement of my mouth once the sound started.
Now, there is one kind of vowel sound where there is movement and those are called diphthongs.
A diphthong is when there's two vowel sounds that come together and the second sound is very quick and short.
So, here are the examples of diphthongs in American English.
/eɪ/, /aɪ/, /aʊ/, /ɔɪ/, /oʊ/.
Notice that there is a flow of air, but a slight movement, and no movement of my tongue.
For all of your vowel sounds, your tongue is relaxed and slightly touching the back of your lower front teeth.
Keep this information in mind when you're practicing your individual vowel sounds.
Good luck!